because to me it was a fascinating in
addition he wrote he proceeded dumb luck
evolved when he wrote them about to the
polish team red carpet you are not
ruling because your member would be
famous family you rule because I was
wondering did you have any effect at all
obviously a theater he had enormously
but that's true philosopher he was he
was extremely good I feel a long time
ago not that in the same time extremely
wonderful example of the men who spoke
the spirit of the day so he you look for
say if you look for sale natural leaders
of the great movement of the fight
against the power of the government
versus society versus society
was a strong and so be there in five
today we would say for democracy and
it's only possible beautiful sink richer
he was very famous of her i was
obviously to say that every Roman lawyer
should be silver from a place after all
risen only when Roman law for hidden
until you see me encode the law is for
Emperor makes to be at all well only
natural for him or if everything else
customary law was he's not observe those
people who obviously participated and I
think that it's not an abscess that
building he obstacle in the whole system
which other way we will call it of 16th
century was the will include of the
different nations living in common rules
it was not the work of the month nature
have participation of bruges perfectly
we must reduce care university it's a
questionable there and he's an easy
different religion collaborated we're
united by politics much stronger than /
collagen had to look sooo much simpler
ways but be someone probably took John
Paul the second doesn't find the most
pleasant idea for Ukrainian polish
relations because he had a Ukrainian or
ruthenian mother a Polish no father who
was an immigrant and he was the grandson
of a group after our den an orthodox
please and decided that when it was a
Catholic priest he would like to have a
wife and then taught her this very hard
and one of the theories of why he
emphasizes this rock-solid is under
Athenian I'm Athenian although we have
no textual proof of this he never says I
should have the right to wife because I
thought my opinion so that we have wives
even though I'm a Roman Catholic priest
but may have been the reason he's
emphasizing it as he was trying to
justify he did live with his wife the
end and he was trying to get his
children recognized as legitimate and so
I think that that was one of his reasons
he was so interested in empathizing
question 2
or anybody
me
routine
unrealized perception of the HPV well
there were 11 unit was to behold here to
check who's good to our teacher yeah I
so much as a political throw and why
things don't happen always hard to say I
mean I think the two theories that I can
think of one coming from or zelinsky's
discussion of the silence of 16th
century ruthenian culture we have this
problem we know